hi YouTube my name's Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara's never seen today I am
watching the fugitive for the first time
Rob Walker has been telling me to watch
this you do for so long and I love
Harrison Ford I grew up with Harrison
Ford and Star Wars and Indiana Jones and
I'm pretty exciting
just like I've even seen Blade Runner as
far as Tamra's never seen goes I
generally go into these action flicks
thinking it's just going to be a generic
action flick and then it turns out to be
awesome
I was the cases die-hard that was the
case with John wick so I'm hoping that's
the case with this one
drop those fugitive predictions I'll
read them so if I said I'll read him in
20 minutes I also use the hashtag
cameras never seen so I don't lose any
like last time detective emoji gun I'm
very excited my hair is already falling
out of its little power buds
let's get started
[Music]
first thing I wrote down is Oh Harrison
with the beard his wife has just been
killed
now everyone's accusing him used to go
to court for it and he gets the death
penalty the death sentence lethal
injection what also how is this some of
the best acting that I've seen out of
Harrison Ford he especially in the
onions throughout the whole film but
especially in his first like 20 30
minutes
holy hell everything so contained but
just he's just oozing out emotion and
sadness for his wife I wrote oh the
whole bus scene I honestly thought he
was going to escape like Shawshank style
in the prison but they waste no time one
of the prisoners is trying to escape so
one of the policemen shoots him and then
they get like derails and the bus like
falls down a hill they fall onto some
train tracks they have to get off the
tracks in order to live obviously and
and Harrison Ford Kimball takes one of
the police in this unconscious and
pushes him out because he can't get out
everyone else left him even his partner
leaves
to get smashed by a train so they get
out narrowly missing the train and the
entire train is derailed and explosions
are going off what was the budget
hey I be good so he goes to the hospital
he works at to get some medicine because
he's been injured in all of this
hullabaloo and he shaves his beard off
which bums me out makes sense
bummed me the Scout though sing me up a
cup of coffee and one of those doughnuts
cool chocolate sprinkles on it so he's
walking out of the hospital he's trying
to get away and figure out what his next
move is and I love how many officers he
gets away from because he shaved his
beard murder average Joe murderer just a
good-looking surgeon rugged handsome
murderer
okuu so he just decides to steal an
ambulance and the helicopters chasing
the ambulance and he decides to go hide
out in the sewer
Kym Curry's just like I'll hi you if you
float such a good Tim Curry Wow camera
crushing it I wrote down Harrison Ford
always looks like he's just a little bit
too old to do what he's about to do and
I don't mean that as an insult at all it
makes it cooler he jumped out of the
waterfall like literally like should
have died and he's like running around
the sewer and it just looks a little too
old to be doing all this and you're
never told to do anything no I'm saying
I'm just saying he looks a little like
he's struggling but in a way that he
like still gets it done I love him for
it
it sounds like I'm faulting him I'm not
I'm giving him credit I think it's
awesome
I wrote wait I'm sorry he jumped out of
a dam and out of a waterfall where is
this in Chicago
it's a giant bridge a giant dam and
there's hills everywhere Hickey like
wait though Illinois isn't this flat I
didn't see any corn in the background I
don't think it was chilled in Illinois
so then he dyes his hair black and he
looks like a
supermodel so I love the way that they
portray Chicago Police isness the
detective is like why did he kill his
wife and the Chicago Police is like
she's rich and the detectives like he's
rich too he's a doctor
I said Chicago Police just goes yeah but
she's more rich it's just so Chicago so
like blue collar policeman like I just
expected him to be holding a doughnut in
his hand like it was perfect he's trying
to figure out who killed his wife while
simultaneously running away from the
police and he keeps going to the
hospital and while he's there and if I'm
the guy with the prosthetic arm he also
like helps save children's lives and
like help with medical cases you know in
his spare time he's a fugitive but also
a doctor you know what girls want in the
guy doc huge coming this fall on ABC
that would get cancelled terrible show
doc fuge you find out that Kimball's
friend is actually the guy behind the
whole thing he's trying to get a new
drug into circulation they all work at
the hospital whatever and there's some
like Big Pharma hate which I love at
this point the police are just trying to
find these guys they're like we don't
really know what's happening the
fugitives know way more than who you do
but we would just be having to find you
then basically the rest of the movie two
prestigious surgeons fistfight it's
awesome Kimble go they killed my wife
they killed my wife pointing to the guy
who did it
the detectives like I know but it's over
now
you know I'm glad I need a rest if it
doesn't I love that line there's also a
good thing between them they both get
into the car as the credits roll the
driving off and Kimble goes that you
didn't care
the detective goes I don't and then they
flash a ward winning smiles and it's a
great ending it was super fun it was
long there was a couple small plot
points that I didn't think was they
spend a lot of time on that weren't
extremely needed really good to see a
Harrison Ford just crush it I love him
so much and so it's always exciting when
you're like oh that's why I love you
because you're so good Rob and Doug have
been saying that I knew
watch it for so long because because
it's exciting to watch something when we
live in the place where my childrens
really thanks oh I'm glad I like it
because also I hate telling them that I
don't like something they really like
just like home alone okay let's look at
some of these predictions you'll ask if
he's ever seen the one-armed man I have
you ever seen the one-armed man silence
such a mystery you'll laugh when you
find out how much that dummy they
dropped off the dam cost to make that
was literally something that I said
while watching obviously it's not a
human his legs like flail open success a
bad dive technique my friend and I would
love to know so if I find it I'll put it
right there so much you wonder if
Harrison Ford is really Aquaman
holy though I really wish the
Harrison Ford's explaining that would be
amazing
oh you'll think Harrison Ford's beard is
sexy Oh sexy
Harrison oh you'll think Tommy Lee Jones
should have won an Oscar and go yes when
you find out he did that's awesome yes
the fuel will like clean shaven Harrison
Ford then bearded Harrison Ford I'm so
sorry Nicolas but that is just a
bold-faced lie I'm a I'm a facial hair
person a true and true tried and true
every time if you're like facial hair
and no facial hair it's always facial
hair David Rogers is crushing with these
predictions you'll be shocked as he'll
to find out there's a sequel what why
you will met you would like the big dive
in the crash the beginning but overall
man I don't think so I really enjoyed it
I thought it was a little long but
overall I thought it was a super fun
story and the acting was so killer and I
think I go into action films with way
too low of an expectation why ieave you
will finally get the joke from the mask
he says it wasn't him it was the
one-armed man I've not seen the mask
that is such a perfect prediction ticket
obviously I'm the worst and haven't seen
anything so that's where I'm ending it
I'm going to do a poll for this but I
think the next couple videos that I'm
going to do are going to be maybe dread
maybe watership down is that a movie I
don't know
escape from New York Rosemary's Baby and
a league of their own are the five that
I have like on the docket for like fun I
don't know
nostalgia key things and I should have
seen probably but always let me know
what you want to see on this I really do
take suggestions from people because I
want to do the ones that'll will get the
most people saying how why I also want
to do the ones that I should honestly
just see so I really appreciate your
comments and your suggestions really
awesome I didn't kill my wife come by
[Music]
[Applause]